hello and welcome to inside Germany
my guest today wrote her doctorate on
weapons control and helped to set up the
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons the OPCW back in the
1990's this organization recently
received the Nobel Peace Prize MIT's
lauki phasors mat she is originally from
Ethiopia and now lives in llena in the
German state of curing in she's a
political scientist a social
entrepreneur and she's also incidentally
the mother of two children
welcome to the show let's start with
family you've got two children but you
come from a much bigger family I think
you've got nine brothers and sisters is
that right yeah well yes I do have two
kids
Felix and Josefina Felix is 13 and Josie
is 11 yes the girl and I'm I come from
10 family whereby I'm number 8 and the
numbers we have a picture you sent us
this is this is the whole family
couldn't fit in obviously no would not
this is the part of the family which we
are born from my mother where we when we
grew up we understood that we come from
different three mothers but this are my
bread there is starting my older brother
than my the other one my sister and me
and my brain you use second from left
then yes yeah a little girl and there is
another one which is missing here as an
artist brother of mine yeah and I want a
straight away show another picture this
is so cute isn't that and I believe
there's a story behind this because um I
think you wrote when you sent us this
picture you wrote chosen to rule yes you
know in Ethiopia when you are born there
is the traditional healer who comes and
sees your spiritual every capacity and I
was was my brother chosen to become a
ruler a leader of the country so I had
to be raised and it was told the man
looks to your energy and says if you
don't take care of them myself and my
brother then their energy will be the
self-destructing so they have an
especial energy and they have to be
raised it especially to rule so I I was
raised and I believe it every time that
I'm a leader I wondered when were you
told that yourself I mean your parents
were told that but you sort of given the
impression from your parents quite early
on that yes for example when there was
the war we had to be divided the
children and I was the one who had to go
to save myself because I'm I'm going to
rule so you get divided we were in the
wartime so they divided as my brothers
and sisters some of us has to go to the
countryside in order to be saved my
father stayed with my brothers with some
of my brothers in the war zone and I was
only seven years old and so you hear it
every time the way they talk to you
certain things for example like a girl
you're not for certain to a lot of girls
thing you should do girl's thing but
plus you should be in order negotiation
so my grandfather was a healer I had to
be in his discussions and under his feet
my father when he went in all the
cabinet meetings I had to go as I was
chosen to rule I was the one who used to
make coffee ceremonies when the cabinet
was sitting throughout the cabinet what
did your father do my father is it is
still alive so he lives in Canada he's a
judge so he was as a judge he was often
in the Emperor time and the King's then
in mangas two-timed and in mid less time
and all this regimes he was part of it
we should and she just I don't want to
stop you talking but we should show a
map of where you come from that am i
pronouncing it right I go dot I got it
yes where I was born
yeah and you talked about growing up in
the wall because this was was it Eritrea
then or was it yeah exactly that is that
is the place where Eritrea today is a
fight I was the day I was born
that's why I'm called MIT Salah is the
day I was born my mother couldn't go out
of the house to give me bears
in the hospital because the they were
fighting over our house so bad because
nobody died and the family in this world
day they called me a protection and
that's why it's called maternal means
somebody like an umbrella which protects
you from the other side and you were
this or treated as a special child
chosen drew and I mean pretty special at
the age of 17
you left Ethiopia and went to Brussels
how did that come a man oh this is
actually a very interesting time when I
because I wanted to go to to brasses
then you need at that time it was a
communist regime in Ethiopia you needed
a special permission to go so I had to
ask a special permission and I remember
my interview was the Vice Minister of
Ministry of Foreign Affairs and my
father asked me how did he give you a
permission to go out and I say what he
did an interview and he asked me what
was the interview and in the interview
the Vice Minister asked why do you want
to go and I said well if the roman
empire's were able to feed their people
give them a water clean water 2000 years
ago if the Europeans they say they have
stopped in the world I'll go and learn
how they did it so there when I come
back I would do it and then he says so
when you come back what would you be of
course the president of the country who
explained because that was the reason I
have to go to learn and he says how many
years do you need and I say seven years
so he gave me a special permission to go
out of Ethiopia seven years and then I
came back home and my father asked him
how did he get that special permission I
told you this is it out the opposition
has to go out before it fell a danger to
the country that's why he gave you so I
came to Belgium and I studied that's why
I studied military science and the
European studies because I wanted to
learn how to stop the world and how to
feed Ethiopians and that's what I did
and that's what I do still and and you
and and you started I think they're even
started working for the UN yes in some
capacity I was 23 I was very young when
I went to the UN
I went because I wanted to do my
Master's and then when I went there they
were only searched - or people working
for the preparatory organization and
none of the Africans were participating
except one or two countries the Nordic
country for sure because they had an
interest and then I started to bring all
the African countries together and bring
them to ratify and I say the reason you
have to ratify this is the article 11
which is for the peaceful use of
chemistry which I want to talk a bit
more in detail about that later it first
of all I want to fight because we've got
to move to Germany what brought you to
Germany love first I came to Germany
because I was asked to lecture and
Indiana University so I came and I you
know I'm small Ethiopian girl lecturing
about unites nation and at that time it
was just after the DDR so people were
impressed about the European Union and
they didn't know what how to influence
it what does it mean you aim and I am a
realpolitik person so I told them
actually there is institutions they have
their own rules and regulations and they
the Member States to influence them if
you want to influence a nation's
collective Nations go to the national
politics so I explained they were happy
then they invited me the year after to
come to again to lecture and this time
they invited my future husband
Christopher and he came with a motorbike
with a later jacket to confront me in
the political science and he was a
politician he was a member on a
motorbike yes with a leather jacket we
should just say I was impressed because
I'm used at that time where LUMO Zing's
was a bush outfit of man and here comes
a simple simple on there is a politician
and then he invited me to walk and in
the forest like little girl and I was
impressive and then I decided to come
back and then got two children
well this is a very good cue because you
talk about walking in the forest in
curing in it cheering it is a lovely
part of Germany it's actually sometimes
called the green heart of the country
illustrated here by a visit to the Hynek
national park here in the middle of
Germany the wooded hills of the highland
region extend over an area of 160 square
kilometers high up in the trees the
canopy walkway offers a unique
perspective on the poured leaf forest
more than 360,000 visitors come to the
Hynek National Park each year when woods
in Central Europe are left to their own
devices they usually turn into beech
forests the beech trees compete
successfully for the sunlight that
ensures their growth
when memens E&E before imagine that it's
foggy which it sometimes is and when you
look at the forest structure in the
background you can imagine it as a
typical german forest were all those
fairytales originated the woods also
magical in the springtime when wild
garlic and early flowering plants and
trees adorn the forest floor or in the
autumn with its bright foliage in 2011
the frost was added to the UNESCO World
Heritage List a big attraction in the
National Park are the Wildcats around 30
of them live in high Nishi visitors
won't usually encounter the shy animals
in the wild but they can't see them in
the Wildcat village in Hojo order
environmentalists have come up with an
ingenious means to encourage wild cats
to settle in forests throughout Germany
they've built protected corridors
connecting the wooded areas for Jesus to
Kualoa ranch ft in the Indian
Deutschland Germany's fragmented
landscape gives the animals little
chance of surviving long-term this
project with the corridors is trying to
enable these wild animals a chance to
move around again in Germany I found
this Afghan [ __ ]
the Heineken National Park has all the
conditions that can make it a paradise
for wild cats as the forest is growing
bigger every day
my guest is MIT's la Carriere sauce
machi who's married to a German
politician who took you for what hope he
didn't take you for a walk with the wild
cats
no but it is really true Turing is very
green and environment and the one which
was so right now is a biosphere reserve
where I'm also actively advice for
reserve in Ethiopia which I do but it
was my husband I have to say no matter
the situation of today that he was the
one who introduced me to all this
environmental aspects and you know
working in the forest and when the
leaves go and it's a beautiful place
cheering her to live especially if you
can can you can doing you know if you
can know and then you can go and design
and you see all this beautiful places
especially in the summer
yeah it's a nice vacation but I mean
turians not Berlin it's not Hamburg it's
not Munich people out there most
probably don't know too much about it
but was it when you went to live there
and settle there must have been a
culture shock of some sort yes it does
because the first time I came and janna
it was under construction because it was
moving from dead there are two from the
East German town and so that is why and
secondly people look at you for sure
because you are they've even had a lot
of black people and we're not a lot of
black people walking straight straight
world and doing I mean teaching there in
the university university and Vienna is
a very cocoon because you have a
university of such institutions you have
companies which are international
companies so the town itself is cocoon
it cows ice are they still yes can't say
right off the international companies
you know everywhere you go when you see
optics you say this is home and but you
know when you go to the outside it is
for the people they have not seen
there has been a case when once I was in
them you know you have this pod when you
have once where the countryside they go
out and like carnival make yeah yes
that's right oppress the village once
and I remember a man came and say I have
never touched a black woman and can I
give you a kiss what would you say so
you have this kind of and it depends how
some of them they are curious so but
they cannot look at you very long and
some of them they would look at you very
long it depends how they express it but
they are when you go to cheering eval
they are you are not only because they
are black you're a foreigner even if you
come from Berlin you are but you are a
foreigner yeah they don't have a lot of
expression to other people huh I want to
a quote from an article about you in the
African times and the headline was I am
a proud German so with this all in mind
do you feel more German than Ethiopian
then I didn't know but actually I I feel
I every time say I'm the best German you
can imagine I'm yes I'm a very proud
German because to be Germany now when I
was a child my father used to say every
time if you want to a civilization go to
the humanism romanticism of Germany not
precision precision so I came to Germany
ok because of love but I didn't only
marry my husband I married Germany which
means gentlemanly the best thing Germans
can give it or Germany can give you is
an instrument of organization that the
Germans often unfortunately they say
being the instrument of organization but
if you are a foreigner and you have that
instrument of organization and that
spirit that energy of being an African
then you at the most best because there
is not a best place for my view when you
want to live to raise your children than
the where I live but you had this
impress
or an impression of Germany as a child I
hadn't asked you that your father was
telling you this is the place to go to
yes I mean my father was impressive of
civilization he's an Oxford so he is
very much civilization oriented father
so and for him for us when you need to
power in I don't know in other places if
you want to say something is precise you
want you say this is German okay it's
made like a German it's made Germany is
it a procedure so for for the
responsibilities I had to go through I
mean if I'm as I'm raised it to lead as
I'm raised it to to deal with the cows
as I'm raised it to make development and
bring peace you need an instrument and
this instrument is the one of the best
is the German to be organized to be able
you know I know it from my kids if you
have a problem and you talk to them they
say okay mama we sit down what is the
problem how do we deal about it facts
are they more there Joe they're more
German yes unfortunately but
unfortunately you know it to be a German
if you are if you allow yourself because
sometimes as a pure German you're not
allowed to enjoy your be German but if
you allow yourself to be the best German
I hope they will allow themselves like
that then you are a good German or how
you have that the possibility surely to
be kind of free what you're saying is
they have the possibility to be German
on the positive size and also to have a
freedom yes but this also will depend in
the school you know in the school when
my son was in a kindergarten I was very
very absent because he was not allowed
to sit down in the norm he was forced to
sit down in the toilet you know and the
German rules and regulations so I I was
irritated so that things which he
learned them in the school to have rules
and regulations and that might kill the
spirit of being free even though you are
free you need a spirit on that we're
talking about your kids I'm looking here
for a pig his his another picture who's
got one of your children this is my
daughter Josefina Josie and this is the
place where she is baptized it and the
woman beside her is the lady who is her
baptizing mother from Lalibela so my
kids actually are baptized in the most
traditional I'm very traditionalist I
love rituals traditional Ethiopian to
church Lalibela and San Jorge and that
is her good mother I was gonna say is it
a baptism mothers bit like a godmother
yes and I think we have the two of them
it's the only picture we've got of the
two of them yes this is this my son now
he is big huge boy and this is the
Ethiopian traditional water therapy
where the priests in only Theo Pia we
have a lot of different therapies one of
them is water the dance which everyone
in Europe knows it which is trans comes
from Ethiopia oh really yes
trans comes from Ethiopia so do you have
this is water therapy and I am doing a
lot with traditional healers and this is
to wake up your spirit when you are sick
if you have a psychological sickness you
go to your priest and the priest gets
this water clean or should I do it and
then spray you three times and then you
wake up so the flow of your energy
within your body wakes up and I believe
that was in nany Bella is in a very is
this very holy city Lalibela is a very
very holy city it's one of the the
number eight
I think places in the world to see where
the the church is made under the ground
was one Mullen urges its own so it's a
very holy place you know it's Europeans
we believe we have also the cross part
of the cross of Jesus crisis and it's a
very important but it is alive it till
Pia when you go to Lalibela to see it
you have to experience it because it's
not a museum it is alive I'm returning
to Germany or actually returning to
another quote and a little it refers to
what you've already talked about in a
way
as a foreigner you said you live much
better than a German in Germany yes you
did I think you know it yourself maybe
because you say when you are a foreigner
in Germany people are very welcoming it
is okay their body language might not be
you might misinterpret ate it but
children and generally even if you go to
the countryside where they have never
met a foreigner they are welcoming it is
by the historical but the only thing if
you are a foreigner and they feel the
best way to keep yourself living in
Germany better is to be every time a
foreign and to deal with this question
how long are you did they ask you how
long would you stay when are you going
back they do every time I'm asked that
cut orientated the other ways you know
you have the best infrastructure the
people are friendly because they are
curious Germans like other Europeans but
Germans specifically because they spend
a lot of time in reading you know this
is a place where books are the MOT sword
so they read a lot so they are very
curious they live from your stories
Germans and they they do travel a lot
you know there is no nation for
travelers like the Germans because the
actors and when you come as a foreigner
if you tell them a story and the way you
help with them also their self personal
development so they are really
respectable but you need to have stories
and being a foreigner you have a lot of
stories hmm so and they love that so the
question is that to find the bridge on
how to keep between this to being a
foreigner but still living and I
consider myself I really I love living
and even if he come and he go to a
restaurant and he you ask something and
the ask her to explain he just came in
from Ethiopia she would speak even
serving you more than much you mean just
because you're foreigner so is Germany
very multicultural or is it just this
curiosity that's the moment you want to
say this is not only a German problem
this is a problem of different nations
the moment you want to stay
is the moment you share the capital or
you share the resources then you are
looking differently then they some of
them wha are and the difficult
situations will look at you but if you
are here only to enjoy and as a tourist
and this and your laughs and you got but
if you stay being happy and taking the
resources where they are not happy team
problems that's better to be a foreigner
and living in Germany okay I want to
quickly move on because we want to show
something about it you you I mentioned
at the beginning you're involved with
setting up of the organization for the
banning of chemical weapons back in the
1990s are you still involved with the
work yes yeah because when I started
actually my life still when I was 17 I
wanted to become a president I went to
study and all this is still the same and
still be President
yes but not yet not yet
I'm not wise enough to become a
president of Ethiopia now because a
country like Ethiopia needs a very wise
person because it is more challenging to
govern a country like Ethiopia than a
country like Germany German is much more
easy things are already done so when I
went to the organization which I because
it's European was attacked by chemical
weapons in the Second World War so we
lost the war with Italy because of their
so it isn't the pride of Ethiopia so I
went to this organization to ban to be
part of the banning of the chemical
weapons but the main reason which made
me help other countries to ratify is
article 11 where is there is the
peaceful use of chemicals will come to
an 11 let's see the peace now I don't
know why we'll come to that because that
gets quite complicated but it also mixes
with something else you do let's have a
look at the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons the OPCW
possibly not very well known until
earlier this year when it was the
unexpected winner of one of the world's
most distinguished prizes
my guest is MIT Schlag chiefly a zorse
machi who was involved in setting up the
OPCW you must feel very proud that it's
I mean was it a surprise for you well it
was a great surprise because I don't
know why I didn't even cross to my mind
that we could get a prize but what we
when the organization was made I mean we
I was number 32 when the organization
was called a preparatory Commission for
the provision of CWC and it was
necessary at that time to ratify the CWC
and not only to sign it but it came when
the Cold War was over when arms control
and disarmament treaties were not so
important because the threat was not so
obvious at that time mmm in the 1990s
sure and then it's 1993 was signed and
we got an interim to force in 1997 and I
finished my job in 1998 because I
brought most of the African countries
Latin American and Eastern European I
was responsible in brasses I was very
very young when I joined the
organization 23 Wow and I used to
remember when we were going like Cote
d'Ivoire and other countries people
expected from my paper is a very huge
woman but I was so slim at that time so
I had to write when I was naive I was
convincing it was possible but it's
important in the international politics
and then anything you do to have certain
naivety and this a naive has brought me
32 countries to convince them they have
to do it and that's what I did and on
naivety do you think the OPCW can do it
do you think you can one day close
because there are no chemical weapons
left in the world
I hope so we would lead at that stage in
general international organizations have
difficulties to cross themselves but to
minimize their activities they would
reach 80% of the chemical weapons are
destroyed so which means we have only
20% left from 1997 until now within 20
years of not even 20 years of activity
the destruction is greatly made now the
the implementation of the treaties are
not only destruction of the chemical
weapons but ensuring there is not going
to be any chemical weapons in the future
development do we need the destruction
people for that maybe the inspection
department will be licensed but they
would not close totally because human
relationship and science and human
relationship is every time a very
careful issue one has to look at it yeah
so we cannot expect the wall it will be
everybody for good purposes I don't
think so most probably it will stay OPC
director's it has to marshal that it
doesn't happen now you've mentioned it
twice and I've put you off because I
wanted to read it up now to relate it to
the next subject you implemented article
11 this if I'm right has something to do
with of course you ban chemical weapons
then there are certain chemicals that
are banned that might be useful in
agriculture yes and this is a problem
you overcame in Ethiopia well when we
ichika ratified like any other african
countries when they ratify normally the
parliament ask us why do we have to
ratify why do we let a challenge
inspection because it's intrusive and i
was saying that if you don't because
then you don't have your industry
develop it so it has got a positive a
stick and a carrot relationship and
there are schedules called skate or
chemical skate or one scheduled to
schedule a came because they have a dual
use technology implication which means
the schedule one the only way you can
use those schedules is for highly and
health issues but in schedule two are
chemicals which you use them and
pesticides and other industries and
schedule threes are a combination of
chemicals in which you might use them
also for weapons i see so there are
these different schedules yes three
classification of other chemicals the
way you produce them is the way routine
and challenge inspection is made but
most of the developing country they
don't produce the schedule one they
don't project this is case
- maybe schedules maybe but they use a
schedule - and schedule three so the
transaction between the the country or
the company which is using it and the
country which is receiving is called a
declaration of companies and this
declaration comes for example schedules
three there are chemicals which used
them in the peaceful application for
example if you want to make a job you
need a Peck team and to make a peck team
pectin is made from a liquid apple
pectin - a powder pectin and in the
process of moving from liquid to powder
the Machine needs certain chemicals and
this chemicals with the company receive
it so if I want to buy a pectin in
Ethiopia I have to give an end-user
certificate which says I am NOT my
relationship with this company is only
for peaceful and you have a lot of
experience with this I know because we
come to your company in Ethiopia copia
which i think you have eleven hundred
farmers working with you and all your
working with them creating I promise it
and then I as promised that I did
disturbed and I got married children and
then when I went back to Ethiopia after
eight years and I said what did you do
with all these treaties and was so there
was nothing so I say I'm going to
implement it the simplest way which is
conservation to conserve the germs you
know in Ethiopia 80% of the mangoes they
get spoiled because nobody could make
them a jar or juice and conserve them so
what I - thanks wrought mainly sometimes
you know poverty and hunger is a
question of transportation sometimes so
you have an in Ethiopia 500 kilometer in
the other western side in Gambia areas
and associates were the fruits fruits
gets rotten and then you have in the
eastern side of Ethiopia where people
have no access because there is no water
so what I did is I went in all part of
Ethiopia have around 11,000 farmers with
all my work and we process the post
harvesting which is normal it becomes a
car
it's been which is a biomass we process
it to jam Jewish deli and I create
companies with them
I mean is it actually is it a little
like the metal stand sort of small
businesses in Germany you've got lots of
little businesses that they're really
looking after themselves
yes normally it is the farmers the
eleven thousand farmers are organized as
a cooperatives and then their children
creates a startup company small company
with us was a copia near the farm and
they process it and if you seed our
products you wouldn't believe it is a
pretty we create a high viable high
quality German cars because it's made by
German senior experts Oh mas and does it
is it imported to Germany I am against
export of food oh it's just for Indian
in the area we are asking it well if you
get our jump you find them in Djibouti
in South Sudan and in sometimes in
Germany also they cost 500 oil and they
I have a big market in Ethiopia so I
don't need to export we if you want to
export it's better to expert cosmetics
and horrible medicine rather than food
it's also we are ecological companies it
gives our principles to export food ok
let's have a look my guess was recently
back in Ethiopia and she took a camera
of ours with her so let's find out more
about her work there here you see me in
a meeting with a representative from a
number of travels organizations Nia
we are attempting to set up structures
or sustainability culture is not he okay
now you see me I'm on my way to one of
my partners I know it appear we we work
with around eleven thousand farmers in
different part of the country I'm often
traveling a long way to visit them this
farm is near Gambino it is a part of
plant cross border but if I reserve here
we are experimenting to find the best
way to extraction battle through the
sheer nuts the nuts arrived and cook
curd and the Shia butter can you use it
in averages like chocolate for example
this is the store where there are plenty
of shea butter chocolate products the
marketing of shea butter for the
cosmetic industry is one of our biggest
projects at the moment Here I am with my
assistants in my open-air office that I
set up wherever I go this way we can
take care of the administration part of
the company as well as being close to
the farmers we have to keep files on
everything we need to fourth in the 21st
century requirement and atmosphere and
technical situation of the 16th century
is a weaving cooperative of salaries
which produce a wide variety of
traditional which you can cooperate
I'm deciding which planet set up an
online shop that will market
traditionally products and we haven't
got the basket but is this the scarf
that appeared this is this carve I mean
there's a the seller this lady she's
also like other diaspora who went back
to Ethiopia and helps with my farmers
also because we we share some common
farmers together why she makes her
waving and put it in the market which is
a beautiful product you said I said
earlier 1,100 farmers you then said
eleven thousand yes we see in the film
there your office which is in a garden
or wherever you go you set up yeah and
it looks completely to North European
eyes most probably lately chaos yeah it
can't be
it isn't that no it's not because there
is a normally when you see me or you see
me working like this you think I'm a
karateka person but I'm very very highly
organized that's why I say I'm a very
good German but I'm emotionally and
rationally organize it so I I care I
mean I live I work in the countryside so
you cannot have a building where you
have offices internet or this and that
so you go to the countryside with my car
we have a car big one office and then
you open your files and you sit down but
you have an index Asian you have seen
there is a German girl beside machine
knows all the indexation you have it in
your mind because it's everything
structure whether it's traceability code
there are seven traceability codes when
you see a file you know where it belongs
that administration is that leg and
assistance but when you sit there it's
chaotic for you because in Germany or an
european
organization has to be organized it you
need an organizer to organize you but
with me is that I organized the world
I don't need organizer to place I don't
need clean places to organize you just
clean it you just clean it and it's like
I have a tent with my kids when we
travel we have a tent you need a laptop
you need the internet connection and you
have your mobile this is what you need I
mean when I come to each other what I
need is my mobile my car my laptop and
my sister and then you are you've go to
any countryside and you do it but do you
come across two Germans perhaps as being
disorganized yet Germans and generally
are emotional for my experience I can
talk only about my experience are
emotionally disorganized that that's why
they need definitely disorder emotion is
that disorganized but and the rational
thing they are organized here as Shekhar
linear system if you come and
adjournments
in an emotional difficult situation they
will tell you we mustn't Zack illusion
which means that we have to talk about
the topic and the topic takes out from
other emotional Lincoln situation but me
I'm asymmetry
I don't think of one way I have a
thought and the totally dispersed like
an organic system and then they are
interrelated so if you touch one thing I
can tell you yes but you know dad and
that's the only way I created the
company my company is a bridge between
16th century to 21st century and you can
only create a bridge and 16th to 21st
century if you are asymmetry because as
a summative you can think of all the
diny
issues which are interrelated domino
affect us if you have that organize it
emotionally and then you can organize it
rational than whether the paper is there
or not you know where the place of it
and you can visualize it easily but in
the de German system is that first the
visualization has to be there the fire
has to be there for you to deal but me I
have that instrument I am a best German
I told it so I know there is a system
and I use that system to organize my
pleasure to organize my
to organize everything yeah I could do
with a bit of that yeah they were this
isometrics yes
we've we've just got a minute left so I
just want to ask you about your favorite
German word it's nice to end on this you
put the borgin height and commute leak
ID which is again this whole subject
good Morgan height means safety security
comfort commute leak ID is also
untranslatable of us since this comfort
is coziness isn't it Germans are very
romantic
they are very loving they only know yes
they only miss it because they missed
the kick because they try to organize
the romanticism within it need us a flow
the harmony is not in color one color
they you know they're they love to make
it white and blue but the harmonies
between the colors between the flow and
that is you know that's a way when you
are it that's what Germans need
foreigners like reading for other
Germans to make it beautiful and that's
why I love Germans because they give me
what I need the instrument and I give
them the love and the move other things
that's a wonderful way to end the
Germans are romantic it's actively as
much it's been wonderful to talk to you
today if you'd like to write in to us
please do to insight at DW de writers
you can write and pose a question to my
guest or to me or just make a comment
please do we'd love to hear from you
always do and join me again at the same
time next week when I have another
fascinating guest on inside Germany from
myself and all the crew here in Berlin
thanks for watching and bye bye
you